be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Diana Prince
better known as Wonder Woman and what
I'm hoping is that at the end of this
video you'll have a strong understanding
of her character as well as why she's
proven to be such an important and
popular character and DC Comics so
Wonder Woman first appeared in All Star
Comics number 8 in December of 1941 and
was created by psychologist William
Moulton Marston alongside artist HG
Peter originally existing as a title
owned by All American publications
because all American had been absorbed
in a national allied publications prior
to its renaming to DC Comics national
look to maintain the existing All
American reader base while incorporating
its own brand of superhero fare keeping
the All Star Comics brand and looking to
William Marston who considered comics to
be a source of Education due to their
popularity among children the creation
of Wonder Woman came by way of Marsten's
wife Elizabeth covered in the 2001 fall
issue of bostonia a magazine produced by
Boston University's Alumni Association
covering the events around campus and
the relationship to the school's mission
statement where Marston had looked to
create a superhero based on compassion
rather than brute force his wife
suggestion of making the hero a woman
resonated with both Marston himself and
DC Comics who looked a tap into female
readership in the post first wave
feminist era looking to the educational
component of comics marcin's initial
design saw Wonder Woman rooted in the
realm of Greek gods and goddesses as
well as storylines that helped readers
to learn the difference between right
and wrong a trait hailing from the
Amazonian culture of our comics which
emphasized strength and self-reliance
however were Wonder Woman was designed
to be a symbol of feminism the early
publications of her character included
concepts of subservience which included
the loss of her powers if a man were to
put chains on her while I haven't been
able to find a source as to why this
particular weakness was included these
weaknesses combined with the fact that
Wonder Woman was physically modeled
after 10 up girls at the time but
maintained the same strength and
capabilities of Superman resulted in
both critics and fans not really being
able to understand how to deal with her
but regardless of these varying
receptions Wonder Woman's first origin
established her as Princess Diana FM
mascara of the Amazonian tribe I'm here
island encountering US army intelligence
pilot Steve Trevor following a plane
crash during his search for a Nazi spy
Diana nursed him back to health and
slowly began to fall in love with him
however this becomes a source of
contingent and that the Amazons are an
all-female tribe and men are not allowed
to stay on Paradise Island as a result
Wonder Woman's Mother Hippolyta who also
stands as queen of the tribe declares
that Steve Trevor must return to the
United States once he's recovered
realizing the basis behind his arrival
however Wonder Woman's comics began to
tie into world war ii by way of diana
being sent back to america alongside
Steve Trevor to aid in the conflict as a
result Wonder Woman donned a pro
patriotic costume of stars and stripes
fighting against the Axis powers now
following these appearances in all-star
comics because Wonder Woman's popularity
fell in line with DC's first generation
heroes during the world war ii era much
like those around her
Wonder Woman received her own
self-titled solo series in July of 1942
under the writing of William Marston
continuing the themes of pro-feminist
ideas combined with educational content
the origin of Diana was expanded to
include an explanation of the Amazons
and Diana herself as I was originally
stated the Amazons had been created
around 1200 BC as a tribe made up
exclusively of women who had been
created when Greek gods and goddesses
drew forth the souls of women who had
died at the hands of men conversely when
Diana was born in the 20th century
because the mascara existed absent men
her arrival came by way of Queen
Hippolyta being told to mold a chunk of
clay into the shape of a baby girl after
which the soul of an unborn baby that
had been inside the woman who was
reincarnated as Queen Hippolyta was put
into the clay baby coming to life as
Diana following this and in order to
give her everything that she would need
to become a warrior six Greek gods and
goddesses offer Diana gifts Athena gave
wisdom and courage Demeter gave her
strength
Artemis gave Diana hunting skills and
the ability to communicate with animals
SJ gave her sisterhood with fire Hermes
gave her powers of flight and speed and
Aphrodite gave her beauty and a loving
heart finally Diana was gifted the lasso
of truth forged by the gods estes
allowing her to force those and snared
to reveal the truth when speaking in
spite of all these gifts and talents
however
diana was not originally a superheroine
as we know her instead were all-star
comics depicted her arriving and
immediately fighting Nazis her solo
series provided a wholesale recreation
which revealed that Diana's initial
foray into the United States saw her
completely naive and lost at the same
time instead of battling Nazis diana had
taken her name from an existing woman
named Diana Prince with Wonder Woman
herself working as a nurse where she
encounters and falls in love with Steve
Trevor
however following William marcin's death
in 1947 the series was handed over to
Robert can occur with issue number two
who put less emphasis on Wonder Woman
being a feminist icon and focused more
on her being a stereotypical American
hero were the works of Canada received a
mishmash above criticism and praise from
leaders of all backgrounds
Wonder Woman also saw her stories being
affected by the growing concern of
colleagues influence on young minds led
by psychologist Frederic wertham and
various parents groups who lead comics
to juvenile delinquency unlike Batman
who is viewed as glorifying crime
through vigilantism Frederic wertham
looked to Wonder Woman as a character
with a lesbian tendencies which in turn
would only corrupt America's youth with
what he deemed as impure urges because a
claims of wertham and those like him led
to the formation of the comics code
Authority as an alternative to
governmental regulation the censorship
of the comics code resulted in Wonder
Woman losing her identity as an
independent woman in place of a
stereotypical 1950s woman who spent much
of her time pining over love Steve
Trevor as well as several other male
superheroes and so because Wonder
Woman's largest audience base was found
in female readers who look to a strong
character of their own where DC
orchestrated the introduction of
characters like Wonder Girl who would go
on to become Donna Troy as well as more
prominent roles for female members of
her family much like Batman whose
stories fell to the point of near
cancellation so too did Wonder Woman
while Superman number 75 would establish
the heroes of DC's comics sharing the
same earth allowing for crossovers
between the titles with Wonder Woman
being unable to hold her own popularity
amidst the newly redesigned and largely
disliked incarnation efforts remained to
rework her character in a way that fell
in line with a comics code but also drew
in those readers who had long abandoned
the title coming under the control of
writer Dennis O'Neil and artist Mike
stukowski with issue number 178
and you should number 179 the two had
gone so far as to strip Wonderwoman of
her powers entirely and an effort to
make her more relatable to the reader
base renaming the title to the new
Wonder Woman in focusing on a powerless
Diana continuing to operate as a hero
using newly learned martial arts skills
the series is critically lambasted by
both existing readers and feminist
leaders alike who viewed the series as
returning Wonder Woman to her position
as a weak woman experiencing a revolving
door of creators including Mike sakowski
becoming both a writer and artist as
well as Samuel Delaney and dick Giordano
taking over the title and the face of
sales plummeting at a staggering rate
with issue number 204 1973 writer Robert
Kanaka returned to this series where he
restored one of women's powers and
placed within the larger DC landscape
covered in 2012 s back issue number 61
from two models publishing with Warner
Brothers Wonder Woman TV show running
strong and approaching his final season
can occurs initial strategy was to
simply rewrite and redraw the same
stories from Wonder Woman's Golden Age
comics well this was only a temporary
measure in order to restore fan faith in
the return of her character between
issues 212 and 222 DC initiated a
storyline titled Wonder Woman 12 labors
which depicted her undergoing 12 tests
for the purpose of proving her worth to
rejoin the team following this and going
into the early 1980s because the advent
of DC's multiverse had already alienated
prospective fans following crisis on
Infinite Earths Wonder Woman's character
was rebooted yet again by writers Jorge
Perez Len Wein and Greg Potter and an
effort to bring in new readers as well
as tie-in to the tail end of second wave
feminism during the late 1980s the coven
in the first and second issues of her
solo series Diana came to America not to
help fight the spread of communism but
primarily on a mission for peace with a
side mission to keep the Greek God of
War Ares from destroying the world in a
nuclear holocaust with their first
battle taking place in the middle of the
streets in Boston the various bystanders
observing the conflict began to take
notice of her amazing powers calling her
Wonder Woman for the first time and the
post-crisis continuity using her lasso
of truth at the battles conclusion diana
was able to convince Ares that he's
wrong for trying to destroy the world
after which she defeats him and returns
home to Paradise Island where the injury
she sustained in the battle are healed
by Poseidon returning to Boston and High
a publicist named Mindy Mayer to help
her spread her image across the globe in
the interest of learning more about
man's world and becoming a global
ambassador for peace during her travels
she meets Superman and develops a crush
on him
considered by many to be a follow-up to
the works of Robert can occur in the
pre-crisis continuity during Wonder
Woman's powerless days as part of the
lowest versus Diana plot threads the
concept of Wonder Woman replacing Louis
as Clark's love interest was quickly
nipped in the bud when the two go on a
date and decide that they're better off
as friends around the same time and as
part of George Perez efforts to reboot
the character issue number seven saw the
introduction of cheetah operating as a
mantle of source similar to Green
Lantern or Captain America where the
first two incarnations of cheetah
existed in the pre-crisis continuity as
Priscilla rich and Deborah domain
respectively these verses of the
characters saw the women dressing up in
cheetah costumes and functioning as
villains for Wonder Woman however during
the era of George Perez the concept was
revisited and that archaeologist Barbara
Minerva physically transforms into a
humanoid cheetah becoming one of Diana's
most formidable villains conversely
George Perez began to use his time to
bolster the Amazonian side of Diana's
heritage while tying into both the
crisis on Infinite Earths event itself
as well as the post-crisis landscape
taking place in issue number 20 in 1988
titled who killed Mindy Mayer stretching
up through issue number 37 in 1990 title
strangers in Paradise and addition to
Mindy's death by drug overdose the Greek
gods were considering leaving Olympus
due to the damage it sustained at the
hands of Darkseid during the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths while Wonder
Woman helps the gods by destroying
Olympus allowing them to move on with no
strings attached the result is that the
Amazons were now able to decide for
themselves whether or not to let humans
onto Paradise Island holding a vote and
after most of their number agrees Diana
invites her friends to visit Paradise
Island as a result and is part of the
larger picture these dichotomies were
designed to boast of the internal
struggle of Diana Prince regarding her
position as an earthbound hero and her
allegiance to her Amazonian heritage in
addition to this with the post-crisis
continuity seeing the Justice League
team revamped as a Justice League
International under Keith Giffen and J M
DeMatteis because the title had
experienced a series of struggles
regarding both publication sales and
popularity going into the mid 1990s in
1997 writer Grant Morrison relaunched
the team and returned
core lineup including Wonder Woman
Superman and Batman keeping it line with
George Perez depiction of Wonder Woman
as a strong warrior unlike other members
of the Justice League Wonder Woman was
more open to using deadly force due to
her Amazonian heritage and identity as a
warrior princess where the JLA line
allowed for Wonder Woman to flourish
alongside her various teammates within
her own solo series the efforts of Jorge
Perez laid the groundwork for future
writers in the post-crisis continuity
including William Messer Loubs and Mike
Deodato John Byrne who had him a letter
take over the Wonder Woman mantle for a
time and Eric Luke who's 25 issue one
thrusts Wonder Woman into an existential
crisis where she not only questioned her
place in a world of men but also her
existence as a world's most powerful
woman continuing these themes within the
pages of Superman Action Comics
Adventures of Superman and Wonder Woman
vol 2 as part of countdown to Final
Crisis writers Greg Rucka Gail Simone
John Byrne and others came together for
the Wonder Woman sacrifice storyline
which saw her breaking her no-kill rule
coming out of 1988 invasion crossover by
bill Mantlo which centred on an alien
force invading the earth during the
battle a gene bomb was detonated which
activated metahuman powers and a portion
of humanity finding himself with the
ability to control the minds of others
former businessman and Justice League
International leader Maxwell Lord used
his powers to seize control of Superman
as part of his larger scheme for world
domination escaping the Man of Steel and
confronting Maxwell Lord head-on after
using her lasso of truth Wonder Woman is
informed that the only way max will
allow Superman to go is for Wonder Woman
to kill him
granting his request and breaking his
neck her actions are observed by brother
I the satellite designed by Batman to
monitor all superhuman activity which
was then broadcast worldwide
destroying Wonder Woman's credibility
and shattering her friendship with the
rest of the league that said while the
post Infinite Crisis stories of one year
later and the year-long event 52 would
attempt to flesh out confusing aspects
of her world including her relationship
to Donna Troy and the years leading up
to the start of the new 52 Wonder Woman
experience a series of waxes and wanes
under the writing of Allan Heinberg
Jodi Picoult and James Robinson all of
which was met with mediocre response
owing in part to delayed releases and
confusing plot lines as a result and
without much outcry in the most hardcore
fans Wonder Woman was slated for a
complete reboot
when the conclusion of the flashpoint
event going into the new 52 that said in
the early issues of new 52 s Wonderwoman
title written by Brian Azzarello and
drawn by Christian Dianna was put in
charge of protecting a woman named Zola
who became pregnant by Zeus and was
kidnapped by Hades a major theme of this
line involves Diana's discovery of her
own origins when she comes into contact
with a villain called strife a take on
the Greek goddess of discord leading
into Wonder Woman subsequent quest to
find her other half siblings while the
events of these early issues would
reveal that Zeus had spawned a litany of
children out of wedlock with his wife
Hera on a mission to kill all of them
one of these children in Diana's older
half-brother is revealed to be Linux
sans Marc the father of cassie sandsmark
also known as wonder girl who is one of
the founding members of the Teen Titans
in the new 52 this line of storytelling
also sees Wonder Woman learning more
about her Amazonian brothers when she
finds out that for centuries
Amazonian women had occasionally invaded
ships and forced him cells on the male
sailors in order to impregnate
themselves after which they kept the
female children but tried to kill the
males by drowning them where the Greek
god Hephaestus intervened by making a
deal to give weapons to the Amazons in
exchange for allowing the boys to live
these themes were expanded on during
Wonder Woman issue number zero however
the largest and perhaps most important
concept of her character came and that
unlike the pre new 52 continuity Clark
Kent had not found himself in a
relationship with Lois while the two
weren't necessarily enemies the idea of
a romance between the two never saw its
fruition
instead Wonder Woman was injected as the
most reasonable candidate for romance
due to her ability to keep up with Clark
both mentally and physically
while this revelation came to the
chagrin of traditional Superman fans who
prefer the stories hold the now-famous
issue of Justice League issue number 12
written by Geoff Johns and drawn by Jim
Lee spurred a social media buzz with the
depiction of Wonder Woman and Superman
coming together in the new 52
however while fans initially look to the
new 52 wonderful in title as one of the
best series released under the
initiative whether it came by way of
weak storytelling or lack of credibility
readership ultimately fell off to the
point that the series began to fall down
the ranks and sales to this end and as
part of the DC rebirth initiative fans
anticipated the release of Wonder Woman
rebirth number 1 which would see your
character return to the preferred
standard using a combination about
pre-new 42 and new 52 information with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end and I will catch
you guys on peace